su tutti il vento gratis a response
oggi nuovo video grandissima richiesta
vi è piaciuto tantissimo il video dei
files di tagli di capelli e a
grandissima richiesta angelo fare la
seconda forte quindi andremo a vedere
altri tagli di capelli assurdi e insomma
cose strane sproni sia niente di
scioccante è come sempre palloncini che
stanno per morire ma sono ancora vivi
quasi due mesi di vita incredibile fa
gensini indemoniati mi hanno detto che
volesse vederli sempre quindi eccoli qua
tiri comodi prete bokor palatine
lasciate un bel live vediamo se questo
video aggiunge 10.000 live non farò
altri video divertenti e volete entrare
a far parte della tra le stelle vi basta
iscrivervi attivare notifiche lo faro on
line su questo video e seguirmi su
integrano il nome anni the stories e
allora siete pronte iniziamo subito
vediamo un po cosa si aspetta
oddio ma perché avere pianeta o parate
come rimosso brown ananas perché mi devi
tagliare così erano anche bellissimi
capelli perché io voglio vedere ora
quando
anche come diventano solo di offendermi
[Musica]
[Risate]
sono rimasto un po calati ma in modo
strano
attualmente stanno le diverse stavano
ridendo dunque avuto in totale ci
vediamo questi dice come potete vedere
se un problema con i miei capelli spazza
una pettinatura invece è rimasta la
spazzola incastrato ne avevo anche già
visto un'altra che aveva spaziare
incastrata quando l'abbiamo vista
assieme poi mi avete scritto nei
commenti che è successo a tantissimi di
voi e che è stato super doloroso e
terribile però piano chiama siete
riusciti a toglierla
penso che odio ma i capelli ok questo ci
fosse strappata i capelli poi la tv e
precisamente da sto pettinatura si no
tagliati ok vediamo anche lei sta
facendo la francia ottimo perché esso
tagliamo così ti l'alto
[Musica]
dai proprio stavo paese un pochino tale
un po storta ma almeno uscita oddio
poverina si è fatto male con me ma non
mi ricordo di aver vissuto le fasce se
sbaglio complesso nell'altro siamo
insegnava che questi non so che sta
benissimo
[Applauso]
mi ricordo che non li tagliava questo
intanto nell'altro video meno sempre la
stessa persona però sono corti ce la
farei mai in campo store titolo no ok a
quanto pare se nei fatti lui da solo
occhio ma ci sono anche i genitori
perché non lo stanno fermando potrebbe
farti male
[Applauso]
toglieteli nuovo in diretta prossimo
addio stato troppo piccolino molto tempo
reale
[Applauso]
forse voleva accorciarli ha fatto un
buco
ok questo è grande senso che da bambino
piccolo gli stava tagliando di le realtà
ti praticamente non piro che cosa se
l'ho fatto da succede questo bambina sta
facendo uno scherzo alla ma ormai
passata io queste cose che ho detto
mamma ma si sa che il padre un veliero
allora dei capelli ribelli come fa non
svegliarsi
preso il suo cantato questi
[Musica]
sono scioccata non comportatevi mai così
con i vostri genitori
come è possibile vediamo un po qual è il
felpa cosa lista che sembrano sopra
questo diceva che la prima volta che
viene qua e là facendo forse una storia
di una sorta di disegno fortunato
facendo sopra anche se mi sembra di kiev
i capelli non ne abbia proprio vediamo
e sempre stand piattissimo come grillino
male come ha fatto a non accorgersene
turista ma qua con la macchinetta che
vediamo questo non posso temete perché
quello che scrivo nome dell'amico cura
in pochi hanno detto che è andato a
partire a rick appelliamo al ticino ha
dato che non può più andare a lavoro per
almeno una settimana serena reati così
tante addio continua pensa male
vado brutta ma come un profitto in aldo
dal basso verso l'alto poverino che lo
pettino questi ma non abbiamo spesi
ok ok in pratica ha detto cosa hai fatto
ieri verdetto che ha litigato con due
ragazze non so se
non so che tipo di litigi in realtà è
l'altro sto sgridando vi sto dicendo non
devono comportarsi male con le ragazze
in forma quindi forse questo taglio di
capelli sarà una punizione o un'ora
tristissimo capito che una punizione
perché si è comportato male come la
ragazza non so cosa abbia fatto però è
tristissimo il bimbo poverino temo che
sia una punizione meritata anche se un
po estrema
penso che sia un po estrema del soccorso
perché i ragazzi mi sembra pentito non
se ne ho visto devo dire alzarlo poveri
dirò io non gliene adesso si succhiano
movimento molto triste questo l'ultimo
video 11 fazioni hanno creato una forza
secondi si sente bene
a
agi wow uguale
un capolavoro bene ragazzi tutti di
sapere quale taglio via scioccato di più
a me e mi ha scioccato quella che a
spazzola incastrata e poi si è dovuto
tagliare i capelli e viso aperto e
volete vedere altri video in cui ci sono
dei mega face
fatemi sapere che volete vedere sul
canale scrivete il tutto nei commenti
lasciate un bel like se volete vedere
altri video divertenti e ora vi lascio 4
caselline potete scegliere la casellina
potete vedere altre challenge drifting
divertenti altri penso altri la juve
scegliete pure quella che preferite e io
vi mando un bacione norme fa alla
pressione